I don't care about what media has to say
about me I'm gonna come out and plate it
right away I'm not trying to make
headlines
man that guy led by example the best
team in basketball right now the Toronto
Raptors
you know let's make this thing work out
I wanted to make his three year
I think at that he's gonna make the
right decision
Kawhi Leonard and Danny Green going
north and DeMar DeRozan going back to
San Antonio I didn't give him a chance
in the East and now that they could
compete you come to an 18 you want to
show them you are he's good player is it
going to be a one-year rental who turned
into something long-term
he can't tell me to roast is the same
players Kawhi Leonard
[Applause]
Kawhi Leonard is an elite player he can
rebound he can defend much better than
DeRozan and he can score at will Kawhi
goes back to the guy we saw two years
ago when he was top five man big that's
a talent upgrade gets it in to Kailash
young Sam
sigh made the toughest move of going
after Kauai
knowing that he was gonna one-year deal
there was no guarantee he'll come back I
just knew that I have to make myself
happy and no one else and I have to
trust myself I'm a fun guy I don't even
know where you sitting it doesn't matter
what anybody has to say about me I Know
Who I am as a person now know how I feel
Kawhi Leonard led by example now he may
have not been a verbally and he may have
not given you a voice but what he gave
you by example presence showing up this
easy to forget how good while anyway he
was a Finals MVP if they make a run to
the case of Conference Finals or even
the NBA Finals Kawhi really had to think
twice about who I really want to leave
here a lot of people were doubting me
thought I was either faking an injury or
didn't want to play for a team you know
that was disappointing to me that all
that was out in the media because I love
the game of basketball I came here and
let's make something special happy we
got a chance to do something special
[Music]
but he doesn't back down oh my goodness
that means this is the reason why he was
bugging everybody that question why do
fools happen or why a hospital rental of
a Kawhi Leonard this is the reason why
those go out and win ballgames in my
estimation qilin is the best defender
ambassador
I mean that guy is incredible you know
you could do it on both ends of the
floor and us everybody it's not just me
out there when you look at his ability
to sport
he was efficient is almost anybody else
in terms of the top superstars me really
just trying to play as perky as possible
I want to be the best team all we said
that just from the start up for y'all
sweet lost to random attic somebody the
game where you know just from there
he'll be bounced back on four straight
and I feel like you just played through
adversity this whole time throughout the
whole playoffs going to Billy mix and
four down someone why heavy low for him
took over the basketball game they did a
nice job Toronto just grinding this
mouth he's the player of the caliber
that can get you over to home and that's
exactly what happened we got a really
good player that's gonna get us baskets
when we need them
if they do get to the NBA Finals until
you go very silly for me to say that the
Raptors have no chance to resign Kawhi
Leonard
[Applause]
just want to win I don't care about
being best player
[Applause]
when you look at the others when you
look at kawatche the difference is the
shot making the ability of Pillai
learners and what that opens up losing
to everybody from this over an 81 fourth
straight you just take your adversity
Toronto Raptors who will be the first
team to host an NBA Finals outside the
United States
finding champion warriors who possess
we gotta go in
miss Opoku saying
congratulations go celebrate now this is
what I play basketball for this is what
I workout for lost summer during the
season
think about the gamble that Masai Ujiri
took looks like it's played out pretty
well
[Music]
lawyers are still favored in this series
and you can rightfully question if the
raptors are ready once he gets into the
series he seems to stay in the series
it's not about what happened on what's
gonna happen you have to stand out mommy
I feel like when you start thinking too
much you don't play well it's all about
reading reacting Kawhi Leonard is
obviously the superstar the best player
and his demeanor is unshakeable this is
the epitome of lue by example and that's
Kawhi Leonard he comes out he keeps
everybody even kid ELISA merger plan
together
they're just confident they're just
doing
I'm surprised how smart and cerebral in
the moment he is
[Music]
I just I just kept striving to having
faith
I'll get to this point he was
double-teamed throughout the night
play 43 minutes the most minutes of any
violent employer
it's unbelievable to kind of see this
dream come to fruition and and to see
the great of Kawhi Leonard dominate and
be the the start there's a new
it's a table
now we the champions
NBA champs your 2009
I'll just kept working hard working hard
and have my life set on this girl right
here
I can't total team no post that mindset
was the same as mine trying to get
trying to get that Larry Obi over there
how so much fun this season
probably the most fun I ever had in the
basketball season this year has been so
fun it is just so sirota me still right
now
kyle has been a big help with me in my
transition you know help me get what I
want my teammates they did a great job
you know walking me with open arms you
know I ended up with the trophy but
everybody deserves II enjoy this enjoy
this moment
[Music]
aha
[Music]
[Applause]
now comes the hard part after the
celebration what is the future hold for
Kauai can you people I live in Toronto
the Toronto Raptors have a fighting
chance of being able to retain it he
wants to be in our life and you know
it's the right decision but if you want
to continue to compete for title there's
no better place than
I've heard that you know he wanted to be
in LA to be done all the right things of
making her happy his players the country
making him feel this is the place to be
for the rest of his career I still have
him ending up with Clippers the lone
true superstar doesn't want to do that
again and if he's going to the Clippers
who Elson is joining you know I just
came in with the right mindset you know
I'm still playing basketball no matter
what Jersey I have on you know he played
through injuries throughout the playoffs
just playing through that so you have to
respect him and allow him to do whatever
he wants good things having a good
people